des frappes antichar qui pleuvent sur
des blindées azerbaïdjanais des images
diffusées par le ministère arménien de
la défense mais qui n'ont pas encore été
authentifiée par des sources
indépendantes
depuis ce dimanche des combats opposent
l'armée azérie aux forces à tsar du haut
karabagh une région séparatiste de
l'azerbaïdjan soutenus par l'arménie
voisine
erevan a décrété la mobilisation
générale et la loi martiale
tout comme les autorités du haut
karabagh le premier ministre arménien
accuse l'azerbaïdjan d'avoir déclaré la
guerre à son peuple et appelle sa
population à se tenir prêts à défendre
sa patrie sacrée da il s'agit d'une
guerre imposée au peuple arménien c'est
une guerre contre notre indépendance
avant notre liberté et notre dignité
transit le peuple arménien était préparé
à l'éventualité d'une guerre car nous
savions que l'arménophobie inimitiés et
la haine avec lesquels la dictature
azerbaïdjanaise a nourri son peuple
pendant de nombreuses décennies ne
pouvait déboucher sur aucun autre
résultat que la guerre même ton
belliciste du côté de bakou a également
été décrété la loi martiale ainsi qu'un
couvre-feu l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
aurait repris plusieurs villages sous
contrôle arménien selon le ministère de
la défense
le président azéri a quant à lui assuré
son peuple de la victoire lors d'un
discours télévisé
les forces armées arméniennes ont tiré
sur nos colonies d'anne caudal ainsi que
sur nos positions militaires la dalle en
utilisant diverses armes break
les émirs chefs y compris de
l'artillerie lourde et depuis plusieurs
directions gala amusé à ta chatte
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise qui est
actuellement sur les positions
militaires de l'ennemi
à la suite de ces frappes
de nombreux équipements militaires de
l'ennemi ont été détruits au real b les
combats auraient déjà fait plusieurs
victimes civiles et militaires selon les
deux belligérants qui se rejettent la
responsabilité de la reprise des
hostilités
sur ces images du centre d'information
unifié arménien à l'authenticité là
aussi incertaine des logements bombardé
à stepanakert la capitale du haut
karabagh le conflit entre l'azerbaïdjan
et l'arménie autour du haut karabagh
dure maintenant depuis plus de trente
ans les dernier affrontement remonte au
mois de juillet des combats meurtriers
au nord de la frontière avait coûté la
vie à une vingtaine de personnes